[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل الزواياه هو من
جميع جوانبه
باولي زياره خارجيه له زلينسكي في واشنطن
يقدم فاتوره 300 يوما من الحرب ويطالب
بالدعم
يوجه رساله للغرب عبر صواريخ يسارمات
النوويه العابره للقارات
وواشنطن تردوا بالباتشيات
طالبات افغانيات يبكون بحرق اثر حرمانهن
من التعليم والعربيه 360 تلتقي طالبه
جمعيه من كابول
وفي القضايا السياسيه التي شغلت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي تتابعونا ايضا
فروه وقلم ماسك تتراجع الى ادنى مستوياتها
في عامين ويفقد في يوم واحد اكثر من سبعه
مليار دولار
[موسيقى]
ننتقل لمشاهدينا لنشاهد هذه الصور
المباشره لوصول الرئيس الاوكراني
فولوديمير
بانه هذه هي اول زياره خارجيه له منذ
بدايه
الحرب الروسيه
ننتظر اذا وصول او دخول زنسكي الى داخل
البيت الابيض للقاء الرئيس الامريكي
نذكر بانه من المتوقع ان يلتقي زنسكي الى
جانب الرئيس الامريكي قيادات
الكونجرس من الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
وسيلقي كلمه
ويخاطب فيها الشعب الامريكي وايضا الحزبين
الواضح بانه اجانب الروسي منزعج من هذه
الزياره التي اعتبر الكرملين انها
ستؤدي فقط
لتصعيد هذا الصراع
تدخل الحرب اذا في اوكرانيا شهرها العاشر
ولغه التصعيد تطهى على لغه السلام خرج
بوتن اليوم
لانها معركه مصريه
حول تطوير الترسانه النوويه تحدث الرجل عن
تزويد الجيش الروسي بتراسانا صاروخيه
حديثه من الطرازات الخارقه ومن منظور تراه
موسكو صبا للزيت على النار خرج وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي حتى قبل وصول زيلين
البيت الابيض خرج بلينكن ليعلن ان بلاده
ستزود اوكرانيا بمنظومه الاكثر تطورا
للدفاع الجوي وامام التسليحي والتسليح
المضاد تبقى نار الحرب
وقودها السلاح
اذا نشاهد هذه الصور المباشره لوصول
الرئيس
الاوكراني فولودي ميرزلنسكي الى البيت
الابيض ونحن بانتظار هاهي الصور اذا
جو بايدن الرئيس الامريكي وعقلته يستقبلان
في اول زياره خارجيه له منذ
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
هذه زياره مفاجئه اعلن عنها
عبر تويتر اليوم
ومن المتوقع ان يحصل خلالها على حزمه
جديده من المساعدات كما ذكرنا بلنكن
استبقها باعلانه عن مساعدات بقيمه 1.8
مليار دولار
العربيه ناديه قلب البيسي اهلا بك ناديه
يعني اجنده زياره الى البيت الابيض وابرز
ما تحمله قائمته من مطالب
اهلا بك راويه بعد هذا الاستقبال الذي
رايناه معا سيكون هناك لقاء ليزي لينسكي
مع رئيس بايدن في المكتب البيضاوي ثم
سيلتقي مع الفريق الامني للرئيس بايدن قبل
قليل هنا امام هذا المدخل في داخل البيت
الابيض كان هناك ايضا فريق امني عسكري
اوكراني دخل قبل دقائق معدوده
ليجتمع ايضا مع رئيس سبايدر مان طبعا هذه
الزياره التي حطت الكثير من السريه تم
الترتيب لها يوم الاحد يعني تم الاقرار
بانه سياتي الى هنا يوم الاحد وبالتالي
ربما الذين يقترحون بانه قد يكون هناك همم
مصادفه ما بين او توقيت ما بين خطاب بوتين
الى البيت الابيض المسؤولين هنا يقولون
لنا بان هذه الزياره تم الاعداد لها مسبقا
في اخر مكالمه هاتفيه بين بايدي وبين
زنسكي في في الحادي عشر من ديسمبر اذا اهم
ما سيتم بحث هو ان هذا اللقاء هو وجها
لوجه بين نازلينسكي وبين بايدن هذه
الاداره منذ اليوم الاول لم تتوانى عن
تقديم كل الدعم عسكري واقتصادي ودبلوماسي
وحشد التحالف عبر القارات اذا اردتي لدعم
اوكرانيا والاداره روسيا هو في الدرجه
الاولى ربما سيكون لقاء مع الكونجرس ليس
فقط مع البيت الابيض رمزيه لقاء همم ربما
زينسكي هو ان نانسي فلوسي ستكون في ايامها
الاخيره لترحب همم هذا الرئيس الذي تراه
همم طبعا همم نانسي فلوسي هو يدافع عن
الحريات في اوروبا وعن الديمقراطيات في
اوروبا وليس فقط اوكرانيا في السياده
وبطرد القوات الروسيه لكن طبعا سيعلن عن
دعم همم اقتصادي ودعم عسكري واهم ما في
هذا الدعم هو بطاريات التي قال لنا البيت
الابيض بانه سيتم تدريب القوات
الاوكرانيات في دوله ثانيه
ان تعطي الابواب الاوكرانيه للدفاع عن
نفسها وليس للهجوم على روسيا راويه يعني
شكرا جزيلا لك ناديه سنعود اليك بعد قليل
في حال توفر المزيد من المعلومات
اذا حط الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي ميرسي
لنسكي في حاطه ريحانه في واشنطن في الرحله
الخارجيه الاولى له من انطلاع الحرف في
بلاده قادما من بولندا علمتني طائره
امريكيه تابعه للرئاسه بهدف حمايته من اي
استهداف زنسكي كان كتب في منشور على تويتر
قائلا في طريق الى الولايات المتحده
لتعزيز صمود اوكرانيا وقدراتها الدفاعيه
خصوصا ساناقش مع الرئيس التعاون بين
بلدينا كما سالقي كلمه في الكونجرس واحضر
عددا من الاجتماعات الثنائيه غادر الرئيس
الاوكراني بلاده الى بولندا المجاوره
ومنها انطلق نحو الولايات المتحده فما هو
معلوم ان لا يطا يران مدنيا يمر عبر
السماء الاوكراني التي يصدها ضجيج
الطائرات الحربيه والصواريخ
[موسيقى]
ملفات اساسيه مطروحه على طويله الرئيسيين
سيعلن خلالها الرئيس الامريكي عن حزمه
جديده من المساعدات الامريكيه الاضافيه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه مليارات دولار تشمل
منظومات للدفاع الجوي وقنابل دقيقه موجهه
للطائرات المقاتله وفق مستشار الامن
القومي
اما وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
فاعلن ان الولايات المتحده ستقدم حزمه
مساعدات عسكريه اضافه الى مليار و850
مليون دولار
وستزودك في منظومه صواريخ الاكثر تطورا
للدفاع الجوي القادر على اسقاط صواريخ
كروز وصواريخ بالستيه قصيره المدى زياره
القادمه لاوكرانيا اثارت غضب الكرام ان
مزيدا من الاسلحه الى كاف سيفاقم الحرب
ولا يبشر بالخير وفقا المتحدث باسم
الكراملين
[موسيقى]
فردوسيات كل هذا بالطابع سيؤدي الى تفاقم
الصراع وهذا واقع لا يبشر بالخير
لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
مع عقد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن
اجتماع الموسعا لوزاره الدفاع لاستعراض
نتائج انشطه القوات المسلحه الروسيه في
عام 2022 وتحديد المهمات للعامل المقبل
خلال الاجتماع الذي وصفته وزاره الدفاع
بالمهمه جدا اكد بوتن ان بلاده ستواصل
تطوير قدراتها العسكريه بما في ذلك
الاستعداد القتالي لقواتها النوويه الرئيس
الروسي
سنستمر في تعزيز القدرات القتاليه
والاستعدادات النوويه ما يمثل ضمانا
لسياده روسيا ووحده اراضيها وبشكل عام
الردعه النووي والتوازن النووي في العالم
وقد تم تجهيز القوات النوويه بنسبه 91
بالمئه وايضا تم تزويد قواتنا بمنظومه فرط
الصوتيه وايضا تم تزويد القوات للمره
الاولى بمنظومه الصواريخ العابره للقاره
يناير ستكون الفرقات اميرال جوش كوف في
الخدمه ومزوده بصواريخ زركون فرط الصوتيه
التي لا مثيل لها في العالم وفقا اما وزير
دفاعه سرقه شويجو فذكر ان روسيا تقاتل في
اوكرانيا قوات الغرب المتوفره ذلك بسبب
دعمها المالي وشحنات الاسلحه المكثفه لك
[موسيقى]
سوناتا
وزياده تواجد العسكري الاطلسي قرب حدودنا
وسعي الغرب الى اطاله امد الحرب والاعمال
القتاليه في اوكرانيا الاضعاف روسيا ان
الاسلحه والمعدات القتاليه الروسيه اثبتت
جدارتها على ارض المعركه هذه العمليه تعطي
فرصه نذيره لتحليل اساليب القتاليه
الحديثه واخوض المعركه التي تشارك فيها
انواع مختلفه من القوات العسكريه
وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
حسين عبد الحسين الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع
عن الديمقراطيات ومن موسكو الدبلوماسي
السابق في تسلاف موتوسف اهلا بكما ضيفي
العزيزين ابدا معك سيد في ستلاف يعني ما
مشكله روسيا في هذه الزياره ما الذي
يزعجكم اليوم الرئيس افلامير بوتن همم
تحدث عن تعزيز المنظومه الصاروخيه
والنوويه لموسكو للجيش الروسي من حق الرجل
ان يحصل على المزيد من الاسلحه ويحمي
بلاده ما الذي يزعجكم
هذا ليس شيئا مزعج بين روسيا ان اتصور انا
تحدثت كثيرا مع
الخبراء العسكريين وهم يعتبرون ان
اييه صواريخ باتريوت موجوده في اوكرانيا
من زمان
ولذلك هذا القرار اليوم يمكن فقط
بالنسبه لي حامل طبعا السلاح جيد ممتاز
ولكن خلال استعمالهم ضد قوات الروسيه قوات
روسيه وخبراء الروسيه
الامريكيه كانت تعودوا
الطريقه
[موسيقى]
من الدعم العسكري
لبلادي ولكن هل هذا فقط ما تح دهوكياف
لتتقدم في المعركه هل فقط الاسلحه
مساء الخير النقطه هنا هو تخوف من امكانيه
تجدد الهجوم الروسي شان هجوم في الربيع
مجددا ربما
لمحاوله السيطره على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف همم هذا على الاقل ما يقوله المسؤولون
الاوكران وهذا التخوف الذي بثتوه للعواصم
الاوروبيه
ولواشنطه وعلى اساسه طبعا وعلى اساس تطور
المعركه تقوم الدول الغربيه بدعم اوكرانيا
حتى يعني في حال تم هذا الهجوم الروسي
يكون لدى اوكرانيا استعداد كامل لصده كما
فعلت في المره الاولى اما صواريخ باتريوت
البطاريه التي اعلنت الولايات المتحده عن
تثبيتها الاوكرانيا الهدف منها ليس له
جميعا نحن نعرف انه هذه الصواريخ تتصدى
لصواريخ تهاجم اوكرانيا فهي صواريخ دفاعيه
والمطلوب الاكبر هنا هو الدفاع عن التحتيه
خصوصا محطات الطاقه والمياه التي تقوم
روسيا باستهدافها صحيح تم استهدافها بكثره
اخر اسابيع ابقى معي السيد حسين وايضا
السيد في تسلاف لنستعرض سويه فاتوره هذه
الحرب اذا 300 يوم مضت على الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا خسائر جمه اقتصاديه بشريه
وخدميه والفاتوره بازدياد ما عدم وضوح
الرؤيه لكيفيه انتهاء هذه الحرب السلطات
الاوكرانيه كشفت عن خسائر ودمار لا يمكن
تعويضه كلفه باهظه لحرب مستمره مع ظروف
الشتاء القاسيه ليس على كاف فقط بل على
موسكو التي يرزح اقتصادها تحت العقبان
اطلقت روسيا
4700 صاروخ على اوكرانيا وسببت بنشوف
16000 حريقه 97 بالمئه من الاهداف التي
استهدفتها قوات موسكو مدنيه وفقا لوزاره
الخارجيه الاخرانيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القصف الروسي تسبب ايضا في تدمير
1132 قطعه اثريه ثقافيه اضافه الى تدمير
2556 مؤسسه تعليميه بينما سجلت السلطات
الاوكرانيه تدمير او اتلاف 114 مرفقا صحيا
نتيجه القذف الروسي مع التوثيق لاربعه
وخمسين الفا
1898 جريمه حرب عدوان وتسببت ضربات
الروسيه التي تقول اوكرانيا انها تستهدف
المدنيين بشكل اوضح في قطع امدادات
الكهرباء والمياه بصوره متكرره في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وسط درجات حراره متجمده
يا بيه
[موسيقى]
البنك الدولي منحه اوكرانيا 610 ملايين
دولار اضافيه لتمكينها خصوصا من تلبيه
الاحتجاجات الاكثر في مجال الصحه الدعم
هذا ياخذ شكل قردين من البنك الدولي
للانشاء والتعمير وهو جزء من مجموعه البنك
الدولي تضمنه خصوصا بريطانيا بسقف 500
مليون دولار الدعم من البنك الدولي يتيح
تغطيه نفقات الحكومه الاوكرانيه في مجال
الصحه ومساعده الاسر ودفع رواتب موظفي
الدوله وضمان تشغيل الادارات العامه
الاساسي بذلك ترتفع قيمه تمويلات البنك
الدولي لاوكرانيا الى ثمانيه عشر مليار
دولار على شكل قرودا وهبه منذ بدايه الحرب
الروسيه علما انه تم حتى الان صرف 15
مليارا منهما نتابع هذا الموضوع مع ضيفيه
من واشنطن حسين عبد الحسين وايضا من موسكو
الديبلوماسي السابق في الاسلام ما توصف
اهلا بكم من جديد همم ابدا معك سيد حسين
سباق التسلح هذا والتصعيد من الطرفين الى
اي مدى قد يصل هل يمكن ان نشهد ضربات
نوويه محدوده
اشك ان يكون هناك اي نوع من الضربات
النوويه اصلا الضربات النوويه المحدوده لا
تعود بفائده كما يتصور البعض وذلك حسب ما
يقول الخبراء انه هي ان كانت محدوده لن
تكون حاسمه وان كانت غير محدوده ستكون
يعني
مشكله تاريخيه
ما ما يبدو انه قادم هو مع حلول الربيع
عندما يمكن تحرك الجيش الروسي قد تشهد قد
تتعرض اوكرانيا لهجوم ثاني اعتقد انه
روسيا تستعد لهذا الهجوم منذ فتره قامت
بطلب الاحتياط وقامت بالتدريب الاحتياط
وقامت في تجهيزات اضافيه وهي تعتقد انها
ستحقق في هذه الجوله ما فاشلت في تحقيقه
في جوله الاولى ان تصدق لها اوكرانيا
اعتقد انه قد يفتح ذلك الباب لي حوار ان
اخترعت روس انه لا مجال لا في الجوله
الاولى ولا في الجوله الثانيه بالقضاء على
الحكومه الالكترونيه
حوار والمفاوضات ولكن سيد في السلاف يعني
همم فعليا همم بهذه المرحله الدقيقه من
هذه الحرب اذا ازحنا موضوع الدعم العسكري
الذي ذهب زنسكي للحصول عليها الا ترمسكو
نفسها وحيده في هذا العالم يعني من هم
حلفاءكم غير ايران ومسيراتها بالمقابل همم
زينسكي وكياف لديها الولايات المتحده
والدعم اللام محدود السياسي والعسكري
والغرب الاوروبيين ايضا ما لديكم
انا اعتبر ان الروسيا متحالفه ومجتمع
الدولي
من سياسه الامريكيه في كل انحاء العالم
في اسيا في افغانستان والدول الاخرى الدول
العربيه مثل ايرات مثل ليبيا سوريا وحتى
بعد محاوله الانقلاب في في مصر وافريقيا
ولذلك نحن لا نشعر اننا معذورين من العالم
الماليه في اقتصاد
وثيقه جدا بعد دول العالم ولكن
ليست روشه
تتحدى الدول
الاطلس برئاسه الولايات المتحده
الجيش
اوكرانيا اصبحت وكيله لامريكا في حوض
المعركه لحرب ضد روسيا هكذا هو يعتبرون في
روسيا لا حرب مع اوكرانيا حرب مع الدول
الغربيه برئاسه الولايات المتحده من
البدايه نحن كنا نتحدث معكم بهذا الشيء
روسيا تعاني كما قال همم بوتين من صعوبات
وحتى لاول مره يتم الحديث عن صعوبات او
مشاكل بالتجسس اود ان اسالك كيف تفسر ما
قاله بالامس الرئيس بوتن عن مواجهه نشاطات
تجسس للاجهزه الغربيه داخل روسيا الا
يعتبر هذا اقرار رسمي باختراقات غربيه
لموسكو دعنا نستمع اولا لما قاله ونعود
للاجابه معك ومع ذلك في السيد حسين
بالاضافه الى اقصى درجات ربطه الجائش
وتركيز القوات مطلوب من الان من مكافحه
التجسس بما في ذلك الجيش من الضروري قمع
اعمال اجهزه الاستخبارات الاجنبيه بصراحه
للتعارف بسرعه على الخونه والجواسيس
والمخربين يجب تكثيفه عمل الجهاز حرس
الحدود حدود الدوله هي اهم الحدود
الرئيسيه لضمان البلاد لذلك يجب تغطياتها
بشكل موثوق
تفضل السيد في تسلاف لاعود واستمع ايضا
للسيد حسين
طابور الخامس
الاساسي
لدول الغربيه
لتفجير او ده في روسيا خلال الحرب
الاساسيه ان يستعمله
في فرنسا
في هذا المجال الان ادت هذا همم نتائج
مؤسس ان اصبح هناك الضروره المليحه
من دبور الخامس في روسيا وكثير من الناس
هربوا الى اسرائيل مثلا
يعني نايل بول رئيس وزراء السابق
وبعض الشخصيات مثل الشباك وهناك السياسيين
والاكتسبين وهناك رجال الاعمال الكبار
لاول مره نعم اعتذر منك ولكن لافتاح
المجال لضيفنا سيد حسين يعني لاول مره
بوتن همم
يعترف بانه هنالك اختراق همم وجواسيس داخل
روسيا وينبه من ذلك ما دلالات هذا الموقف
يعني هو يبحث عن كبش محرقه
بتبرير الفشل الروسي بعد 10 اشهر من الحرب
التي اودت بحياه كثيرين من الروس يعني غير
الاكران
والتي كلفت البلاد
ضربات اقتصاديه كبيره لابد ان يقوم بالقاء
اللائما على يعني طابور خامس او على دول
الغرب طبعا يعني انا احب ان اذكر السيد
انه روسيا هي التي دخلت هذه الحرب لم تبدا
لو لم تتحرك القوات الروسيه الى داخل
اوكرانيا فنحن كل مره نقول انه يحاول
روسيا تصوير هذه الحرب انه حرب الاطلسي
تحالف الاطلسي ضد روس ولكن التحالف الاطلس
رجاء رجاء الرئيس بوت يعني اذا ذهب وزراء
الخارجيه ذهب مكروه شخصيا رئيس فرنسا
ذهبوا قالوا له يعني همم
نقوم بفرض اي عقوبات ولكن لا ولكن تحديد
هذه النقطه انا انتهى وقتي ولكن يعني لن
نقول الامور كما هي روسيا من البدايه كان
لديها مخاوف امنيه همم على حدودها لا تريد
وجود لي الاطلسي على حدود شمال الاطلسي
ولاحقا منذ فتره مكروم قال نحن نتفهم هذه
المخاوف يعني لو اخذت هذه المخاوف بعين
الاعتبار منذ البدايه ربما لم نكن وصلنا
الى مرحله الحرب وما حصل على كل الاحوال
اشكركم ضيفيه من واشنطن حسين عبد الحسين
وايضا من موسكو الديبلومات السابقه
تتابعونا بعض الفصل
سيارات الاسعاف في بريطانيا يفاقم ازمه
القطار
[موسيقى]
اذا نشاهد هذه الصور
الرئيس الامريكي وايضا الرئيس الاوكراني
فولز ميرسكي
خلال اجتماعهم في البيت الابيض
واا هجوم على المدنيين
هجوم على المستشفيات والمعاجم وهو يحاول
ان يستخدم الشتاء كسلاح لكن شعب الاوكراني
يواصلوا اعطاء المثال وهو مصدر للهام بفضل
شجاعته وكذلك مقاومته وتصميمه على
المقاومه الشعب الامريكي يقف الى جانبه
نحن مع حلفائنا في اوروبا واليابان واماكن
اخرى نحرص على ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
والامنيه الى اوكرانيا نناقش ذلك لاحقا
نريد ان تستطيع الدفاع النفسي اولي ذلك
سوف نقدم لاوكرانيا بطاريات بيتريوس وكذلك
سنقدم التدريب لقواتكم لاستخدام هذه
المنظومات
نواصل وما حلفائنا وشركائنا ايضا فرض تكلف
على الكرملين وكذلك السعي الى سلام من
عادل رئيس الاسكي الشعب الولايات المتحده
تقف الى جانب شعب اوكرانيا العظيم وتقف
الى جانبكم ايضا وانتم قد اخترتم ااا كرجل
العام في مجله تايم وانت بالنسبه لنا رجل
العام شكرا شكرا السيد رئيس انه لشرف عظيم
لان كنا متواجد هنا هنا
وشكرا لك على الاستضافه والدعوه
والسيد الرئيس رغبته في القدوم ال السيد
رئيس على علم انني لم اتمكن من القيام
بذلك في السابق بسبب الوضع الامني لكني
لاني استطعت وبفضل تحسن وضع الامني وكذلك
الدعم الذي تقدمونه نحن ندرك ان لدينا
قضايا مهمه
سنناقشها وكذلك هناك الكثير من التحديات
في اوكرانيا وفي اوروبا وفي العالم
انطلاقا من الطاقه والوضع في ساحه المعركه
ولكنه ناكد على تقديري من صميم فؤادي
نيابه عن الشعب الاوكراني والام
والاكرانيه لكم انتم السيد الرئيس على
دعمكم الكبير والدور القيادي الذي قمتم به
حيث وانت مساعدتمونا وتس قلنا لان الحرب
لم تنتهي بعد
وهذه هي قيادتكم اشكرك عليها السيد الرئيس
همم
واشكر ايضا للحزبين اشكر وال اشكركم على
الدعم
وكذلك الدعم الذي قدمه
الشعب الامريكي
اقدم شكرا نيابه عن الشعبي الاوكراني
للشعب الامريكي وانا اسمي هذا الدعم
الكبير
وعندما نقول نسمي همم
ذلك يتطلبوا ان يشعر الانسان بهذا التقدير
شكرا جزيلا لكم
وبالامس كنتوا على متني حافي لافي باخذ
منطقه في شرق البلاد وقد لقيته الكثير من
الاتصالات الهاتفيه
والرغبته في ان اقول لكم ان هناك
همم هو بطل الحقيقي هذا الرجل طلب مني همم
انقل تحياتي الى الرئيس
وهو نقيب في
السلاح المدفعيه وهو رجل شجاع وقال انتم
ايضا سياده الرئيس رئيس
وود ان اسلمكم هذا الوسام الوسام اشرف
العسكري الذي قدمه
لهذا الضابط الاوكراني وطلب مني ان اسلمه
لكم
وهذه هي الشهاده التي سلمتها له تحمل
وتوقيعها هل يوجد اسم هذا
الضابط نعم اسمه مكتوب على
الشهاده اسمه
ااا شكرا شكرا انا الذي اشكركم فخامه
الرئيس وهو قال لي ان الكثير من الجهود
بدلت من اجل انقادي الاوكرانيين لدينا
تقليد ايضا نحن
وابني همم حرب في
العراق ولديه طبعا وسام
وساحرص على ان هذا الضابط سوف يحصل على
هذا الوسام ايضا شكرا جزيلا لك وهذا شرف
عظيم ليش شكرا لكم همم ممثله وسائل
الاعلام على حضوركم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذن نكتفي بهذا القدر لهذا اللقاء الذي
جمع الرئيس الامريكي
والرئيس الاوكراني في اول الزياره له الى
خارج
حدود خارج حدود الوطن اوكرانيا طبعا
زيلينسكي تحدث بانه الحرب لم تنتهي ونقدر
دعم امريكا المستمر لاوكرانيا همم وايضا
تحدث بانه الوضع الامني تحسن لذا انا هنا
همم بيضا قدم بطاريات لاوكرانيا وشدد على
دعم اوكرانيا الدفاعي عن نفسها
وسايلتقي ويلقي همم بعد همم فتره من الوقت
زي لينسكي خطابا امام الكونجرس الامريكي
[موسيقى]
بدلا من ان تسعى حركه طالبان لتقني على
العالم بالاعتراف بحكومتها المسيطره في
افغانستان عفوا تستمر باتخاذ خطوات تعقد
مسارها وتزيد من عزلتها الدوليه اذا اعلنت
حكومه طالبان ان الجامعات الافغانيه باتت
محظوره لاجل غير مسمى على الفتيات
المحرومات اصلا من التعليم الثانوي منذ
وصول الحركه الى الحكم وزير التعليم
العالي في حكومه الطالبان ندى محمد نديم
قال في رساله موجهه الى كل الجامعات
الحكوميه والخاصه ابلغكم جميعا بتنفيذ
الامر المذكور بوقف تعليم الاناث حتى
اشعار اخر وسرعان ما لبى مسلحول حركه
الامر الحكوميه بمنعهم اليوم مئات الشابات
من دخول حرامي جامعات افغانيه امر سدد
ضربه اخرى لحقوق الانسان في هذا البلد
بدورها ردت بعض الجامعات في افغانستان
الطالبات ومنعتهن من الدخول اليوم عقب
القرار
فقالتشيستا وهي تدرس اداره الاعمال في
جامعه خاصه بكابول ذهبنا الى الجامعه وكان
رجال طالبان عند البوابه واخبرونا انه
يحضر علينا دخول الجامعه حتى اشعار اخر
وكما نرى الفتيات
تبكي
[موسيقى]
خطوه طالبان اثارت انتقادات دوليه واسعه
اذا عبرت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان
لها عن استغرابها واسفها لقرار حكومه
تصريف الاعمال الافغانيه بمنع الفتيات من
حق التعليم الجامعي واضافت الخارجيه
السعوديه ان الرياض تدعو حكومه تصريف
الاعمال الافغانيه للتراجع عن القرار
واعتبرته امرا يتنافى مع اعطاء المراه
حقوقها اما البيت الابيض فقال ان الولايات
المتحده على اتصال بالحلفاء حول قرار
طالبان وذكرت المتحدثه باسمي مجلس الامن
القومي ادريان واتسون في بيان ان الولايات
المتحده تدين قرار طالبان الذي لا يمكن
الدفاع عنه بمنع الافغانيات من تلقي
تعليمات من جهتها اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه انا لينابير بوك ان حكومه
الطالبان قررت تدمير مستقبل افغانستان
بحضر التعليم الجامعي على النساء وكتبت في
تغريده بتدمير مستقبل البنات والنساء في
افغانستان تكون ط قررت تدمير مستقبل بلدها
بدورها او بدوره ابدى الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيرش قلقه العميق ازاء
قرار طالبان داعيا الحركه الى ضمان
المساواه في الحصول على التعليم على كل
المستويات
[موسيقى]
وتنضم الينا من كابول سحر اكبر الطالب
الجامعيه في كليه الاعلام سنه رابعه
ونهائيه اهلا بك سحر يعني انت
بالسنه الاخيره يعني قبل التخرج اخبرينا
عن لحظه ابلاغك بهذا القرار من قبل طالبان
اين كنت وهل كان متوقع عن هذا القرار
طالما احترام خدماتها معي ازيك
[موسيقى]
واقول ان اليوم كان يوما مؤسفا بالنسبه
لنا نحن النساء
اللواتي تطهد حقوقنا في داخل البلاد حق
الخروج من المنزل اليوم اخر الحقوق كان حق
التعليم الذي سلب من
هؤلاء
يعني حطموا قلوب البنات والفتيات
والنساءات جدا
وحق التعليم هو حق اساسي همم تحرم منه
المراه في المجتمعنا وهذا مؤلم جدا في
الحقيقه بالنسبه همم لنا همم لكل من يتابع
الاوضاع في افغانستان طيب سحر يعني انت
هذه هي السنه الاخيره كام مثل ما ذكرنا ما
هي يعني ماذا ستفعلين يعني انت كنت
ستتخرجين من الجامعه لتعملي لاحقا ما
مخططاتك هلك القدره ربما على الانتقال الى
بلد اخر
ماذا تفعل الفتاه الافغانيه في هكذا حالات
لانه اذا تم منع المجتمع الافغاني ونصف
المجتمع عن النساء من حق التعليم واا
رسم مستقبلهم انا همم مثلا في السنه
الاخيره همم كنت ادرس في الصحافه مثل
الكثيرات يدرسنا في الطب وفي التعليم وفي
مختلف الفروع التي تحتاجها المجتمع يجب ان
نفهم
السلطات ان منع الفتيات من التعليم
سيؤدي الى تدهر الاوضاع اكثر ولا يساعد في
الاستقرار
دي كان مخها مش فاهمهم في
غنسطه غريبه
لكي يتضامن مع المجتمع الافغاني
والمجتمع الافغاني لا يستحق كل هذا التعسف
والظلم سحر كلمه اخيره توجهها لي حركه
طالبان وللعالم
ماذا تقولين لهم
مجتمع الدولي وكل الدول التي تسمع صوت
النساء الافغانيات ان يهبوا لنجدتنا لانه
لا احد يسمع صوتنا في داخل افغانستان نحن
نشعر باننا وحيدون اذا كنا نحن مواطنا
تبغانيات فيجب ان يتم الاعتراف بحقوق لانه
طالب اللي هو المتحده وكل المجتمع الدولي
ان يحترموا حقوقنا ويضغطوا على السلطات كي
تلغي هذا القرار المجحف وايضا همم
ونقول لهم همم دعونا نضع يجنن بها وان
نبني بلدنا بدل تهميش النساء الافغانيات
ونحترم حقوق جميع فئات المجتمع لان هؤلاء
البنات هم البنات
ايضا الله لم يخلق احد لكي ااه يطهد الناس
بني ايه جبتهم
ويجب ان تكون المحبه هي التي تسود بيننا
وليس اضطهاد بعضنا البعض الاخر شكرا جزيلا
لك سحر اكبر الطالبه الجامعيه في كليه
الاعلام سنه رابعه
العامه تامر بحاله الفنانه منه شلبي
للمحكمه الجنائيه التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في مصر مره ثانيه العامه
باحاله الفنانه منه شلبي للمحاكمه
الجنائيه
لمعاقبتها على ما اسند اليها من احرازها
لماده الحشيش المخدر بقصد الطعام واستمعت
انيابه العامه لخمسه شهود على الواقعه وما
توصلت اليه التحريات وتسجيلات المراقبه في
مكان ضبطها بالاضافه الى نتائج فحص المعمل
للمضبوطات
سمير ثروه اسال الماسك بالتراجع ذلك بعد
ان فقد منصبه كاغنى رجل في العالم الاسواع
الماضي وهبطت ثروه ماسك بسبعه مليارات
و700 مليون دولار يوم امس نتيجه التراجع
حاد في سعر اسهم شركه تسلا لتصل ثروته الى
ادنى مستوياتها في عامين وحسب احصاءات
بلومبرج بلغت القيمه الحاليه لثروه ماسك
نحو 104 او 148 مليار دولار وفقد ماسك
اكثر من 122 مليار دولار من ثروتها هذا
العام لتتجاوز خسائره اجمالي ما حققه في
العام 20 واحد و 20
الى سوره اليوم وهي لسيدتين من المانيا
توجهتها الى راس شجره الميلاد الرئيسيه
المثبته في ساحه بوابه براند بورد في
العاصمه الالمانيه برلين صباح اليوم
وصعدت على ارتفاع 15 مترا بواسطه منصه
الرفع وقامت بقطع الجزء العلوي من قمه
شجره عيد الميلاد المثبته قرب البوابه في
برلين مثل ما ذكرنا اشاره الى ان راس
الشجره لا يمثل سوى راس الكارثه البيئيه
القادمه
الى تصريح اليوم وهو لالم ماسك الذي قال
عبر تويتر
على البديل وقال ماسك في تغريده ساستقيل
من منصب الرئيس التنفيذي بمجرد ان اجد
شخصا احمقا بما يكفي لتولي الوظيفه بعد
ذلك ساقوم فقط بتشغيل فراق البرامج
والخواتم
اليوم من العاصمه ايرز فخلال الاحتفالات
بفوز المنتخب الارجنتيني حول مشجعان القفز
من اعلى احد الجسور للوصول الى الباص الذي
يقل راقص التانجو والاحتفال معهم والتقاط
الصور التذكاريه لكن احد المشجعين لم يسقط
داخل الباص بل في الشارع ما تسبب ببعض
الاصابات له
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني انتهت ملفاتنا واخبارنا اليوم ننتقل
الى الزميل العادل للمزيد من الزوايا
والاخبار مساء الخير يا عادل مساء النور
في افغانستان والطالبات الحلم النساء
التعليم
[موسيقى]